so we have an interesting looking
diagram here let's say we know a few
things about this diagram let's say we
know let's say we know that that line
m'kay
so line MK is parallel to line and J and
J so this line is parallel to this line
this is line MK this is line and J now
given that and all the other information
on this diagram I'm hoping to prove that
the measure of angle this angle right
over here l MK l MK is equal to is equal
to the measure of this angle right over
here and this angle is L we could call
it angle L and J is equal to the measure
of angle L and J or another way of
writing this the measure of LM K is B is
B and the measure of L and K is a so we
want to prove that B is equal to a using
all of this information that we know and
like always I encourage you to try this
on your own before I walk through it all
right so let's walk through it so the
first thing you might see is okay look I
have this I have a triangle formed up
here and actually let me let me sketch
out this triangle triangle M L K and
what do we know about angle the measure
of the angles of the interior angles of
a triangle
well the measures of the interior angles
of a triangle are going to add up to 180
degrees so we know we know that B which
is the angle the measure of this angle
plus the measure of this angle plus C
plus C plus this the measure of this
right angle so it's gonna be plus 90 so
let me write it plus 90 plus 90 degrees
is going to be equal to if you these are
this is this is sum of the measures of
the interior angles of this triangle
well for any triangle that's going to
sum up to 180 degrees and so if we
subtract 90 degrees from both sides
we're going to get
we're going to get B plus C B plus C is
equal to is equal to 180 degrees minus
90 degrees is going to be it's going to
be 90 degrees or if we wanted to write B
in terms of or if we want to solve
explicitly for B we could subtract C
from both sides and we could write B B
is equal to is equal to 90 degrees minus
C 90 degrees 90 degrees minus C alright
so that's interesting so that's that's
one way of expressing B now can we
express a in a similar way and once
again at any point you get inspired I
encourage you to do that well if we look
carefully we see that we have a triangle
N and it's hard to read we have a
triangle let me see this I'll do it in
purple we have triangle N and L J this
really big triangle it's really most of
the diagram nlj and what's interesting
about n LJ is that this is another right
triangle having a right angle here C is
one of the measures of one of the
interior angles and then a is a measure
of the other interior angle so we can
write something very similar we can
write we can write a so that measure
plus C plus C plus 90 degrees plus 90
degrees is going to be equal to is going
to be equal to 180 degrees and actually
the last time around I wanna I should
write the C in that purple color it's
very close to the magenta color but the
C is in that purple color alright so
what can we do here well we can do the
exact same process to solve for a if we
subtract 90 from both sides and we
subtract C from both sides what do we
get we get a a is equal to so once again
if you subtract 90 from both sides
you're gonna get 90 on the right hand
side 90 degrees and if you subtract C
from both sides you're gonna get 90
degrees minus C now this is interesting
be is equal to 90 degrees my
see and a is equal to 90 degrees minus C
so 90 degrees minus C is equal to a it's
also equal to B or we can now say that a
we can now say that a must be equal to B
that the measure of angle LMK which is B
is equal to the measure of angle Ln J
which is equal to a